a 42 here in 1989 Thai national charm I
tip yeah so received the longest prison
sentence ever 140 1078 years her crime
well she ran a Ponzi scheme that
defrauded more than 16,000 people of two
hundred and four million dollars you've
heard of a Ponzi scheme but do you know
where the phrase comes from meet the con
man that gave cunning its very own name
the very suave Charles Ponzi born in
Italy he moved to America and by the age
of 40 he had earned a reputation for
being one of the world's most infamous
swindlers he arrived in America with
just two dollars fifty in his pocket
he set up an investment company called
the securities exchange company he
promised anyone who invested a 50%
return on no investment within a month
in the first month eighteen people
invested a total of eighteen hundred
dollars into his company and sure enough
Ponzi delivered on his promise of a
fifty percent return but how well he
wasn't actually investing any money at
all he simply took the money from the
new investors and gave it to old
investors this is essentially the idea
of what we now know as a Ponzi scheme
whilst the idea sounds great for
investors who get in there early Ponzi
schemes are not sustainable and all of
them will eventually collapse at which
point the schemer will take off with
everybody's money and do a runner just
six months after Charles Ponzi set up
his company he was earning a staggering
1 million dollars per day
of course the scheme inevitably
collapsed by this point a whopping 75%
of Boston's police force had already
been investigating Ponzi for while
suspecting that his miraculous
investment scheme had a few legal holes
a short while later he was sentenced to
just five years in prison
investors lost millions of dollars
answer the infamous Ponzi scheme had
been born many such schemes still go on
to this very day around the world
Charles Ponzi was a confident man he was
a con man but one would have to be
immensely confident to achieve what
Czech Republic born count Victor Lustig
did he sold the Eiffel Tower twice
the Eiffel Tower wasn't always the
gleaming beacon of Parisian culture as
we know it today in 1925 the Eiffel
Tower was becoming rundown the cost to
maintain it was far too great newspapers
were soon reporting about how derelict
the tower had become and there were even
rumors that it was soon to be demolished
Victor Lustig saw opportunity he had a
professional forger create fake
government stationery and gathered
together six scrap metal dealers at a
confidential meeting in one of Paris's
most prestigious hotels hotel decree on
under the guise of a government employee
he told the scrap dealers that due to
the overwhelming expense of maintaining
the Eiffel Tower the city wanted to sell
it for scrap metal Lustig even took the
men in a limousine tour around the tower
one of the scrap dealers a mr. Andre
Poisson fell for the grand show that
lustick had cleverly curated I mean if
your name is literally mr. fist and you
don't be rather gullible aren't you
froth on made a bid for the tower and
later handed Lustig a briefcase full of
cash because that's how all legit
business deals are done Lustig then
swiftly hopped on a train to Vienna
so did Pross on go to the police after
he realized he had bought absolutely
nothing new he was far too embarrassed
and said nothing to anyone no more than
a month later and Lustig returned to
Paris and was once again in a hotel with
six more scrap dealers and yes
for a second time he managed to
fraudulently sell the Eiffel Tower but
this time the police were informed but
by that point mistake had already fled
Lustig was such a confident guy that he
later went on to scam infamous gangster
Al Capone out of $50,000 in a fraudulent
stock deal
Lustig isn't the only confidence
trickster that has successfully sold the
national icon an Indian man known simply
as nut roll
sold the Taj Mahal not once not twice
but three times nut wallah was a
stereotypical con man he used more than
50 aliases and was said to be a master
of disguise
he was also highly skilled at forging
signatures it is said that was a single
glance at any signature he could
instantaneously replicated like a pro
not wall would pose as a government
official and approach wealthy tourists
offering to sell them famous Indian
monuments for thousands of rupees most
people find its most incredibly
suspicious yet despite lifts not one on
managed to successfully sell the Taj
Mahal
three times he also sold the red fort
and even the President of India's very
own home the Rashtrapati Bhavan the
prolific con man was wanted in eight
state for over 100 different cases of
fact and fraud he was eventually caught
and sentenced to 113 years in prison but
astonishingly it was locked up eight
times and all eight times he managed to
escape it said that he only served 20 of
the 113 years that he was actually
sentenced to he was last seen in 1996 at
the age of 84
the police have managed to find him once
again and arrested him but sure enough
he gave them the slip and he was never
again his brother claims that he died
later that year but his lawyer claims
that he didn't die until 2009 nobody
knows for sure
although some say that he may even still
be alive today out there somewhere
no there's pretending to sell the Eiffel
Tower and the Taj Mahal and then there's
pretending to sell something that
doesn't exist can't be seen and nobody
has ever heard of this actually happens
several times in the early 19th century
Scottish native Gregor McGregor told all
his acquaintances that he was actually
the Prince of a land called place along
the Honduras Black River he claimed that
his mysterious land was a little larger
than Wales and bragged about it's
incredible maize harvest he said that
the water with the purest and most
refreshing in all of the world the
riverbeds are lying with chunks of gold
he said the forests full of rare game
and the trees grow the most exotic
fruits this identic govision of a rich
fertile land full of treasures was a
stark contrast to the wet bleakness of
the rugged Scottish landscape so then
it's no surprise that when McGregor
roughed investors to contribute money to
help him gather resources from his
homeland promising to return the
investors initial investment many times
over that they snapped up the offer in
their droves at the time Central and
South America were upcoming regions and
were already popular with investors
McGregor even drew up maps of the island
and commissioned artists to draw
pictures of his made-up homeland which
he could use as further proof to
investors McGregor gathered together 1.3
million pounds of investments the
equivalent of 3.6 billion pounds today
in September 1822 seven ships set sail
with 250 settlers and some of McGregor's
investors so that they could set foot
upon create and see the mystical
they had plugs so much money into with
their very own eyes of course the
coordinates that they were given were
pulled out of thin air and after two
months voyagers see they did find a
random desolate part of Honduras but it
certainly wasn't anything like the
beautiful or Zdenek paradise it pays
that he has described to them they
attempted to settler anyway since they
had a little choice but within a few
weeks the vast majority of them had died
would soon return to Scotland of the
settlers and invested demise an McGregor
skip town he fled to France and he felt
so guilty about sending 250 Scottish
people to perish at sea in search of a
made-up Island but he did it all again
within just a few months he had swindled
the group of French investors out of
their hard-earned cash and he assembled
a new group of French settlers and
investors ready to embark on another
long sea voyage to set up their new home
on PA what's the French authorities
weren't quite as laid-back as the
Scottish and they created a commission
to investigate whether piays actually
existed of course when the French
authorities discovered that there were
rather obvious and blowing holes in
McGregor's story they swiftly threw him
in jail but did that stop him no even
after he was convicted and everybody
knew his fairytale Island was a lie
McGregor continued to sell non existent
land to the various gullible and stupid
European nobility thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon which
really helps out the channel and you can
get some cool awards like early access
to all my videos click here to watch
another video and if you haven't already
don't forget to subscribe